facilities
some development
so
I will speak very systematic and
complete introduction to the analysis
and everything in our lectures so
instead I prefer rather to to give it as
a sort of
introduction to basic Notions and basic
methods that are used just to illustrate
things that happen in this area
and of course there are systematic
lectures of this thought so I know that
gill color is giving a long course of
lectures here in Berkeley now
which will be covering more or less this
area and much much more and if you want
to to look for something that is already
written down there is for for example
Ryan O'Donnell's block and booking
preparation analysis of Boolean
functions so I would I would recommend
checking there if you if you want to
look for more details
also I should say that the slides will
be made available once the the lecture
lectures are finished so you don't need
to take notes of everything that appears
here
this will be available later on
and well that's
the end of the introduction that's
let's introduce the basic notation so by
n bracket I will just denotes usually
the set of consecutive integers from 1
up to n
by discard Cube which is sometimes so
called hyper-q we will mean just the
negative one world in power n
and we'll equip it with a normalized
counting measure which is a probability
measure and this of course is a product
probability measures we take
the measure assigning probabilities one
half and one half to both elements of
the two elements at negative one one and
then we just take the product measure
right so this is the same as normalized
counting measure and if we look at this
structure as a higher group
a compact group with pointwise
multiplication then this will be the
same as harm measure
ment
so
quite many things that I will discuss
can be extended in a reasonable way at
least as long as n is finite to more
General product probability spaces and
also
quite often things may be extended
either on the cube or on marginal
product probability spaces even to the
case of infinite products and sometimes
even uncountable products but I will not
go in this direction for many reasons
the basic reason is that I want to give
a very simple presentation very
Elementary presentation just to make
make those of you who are not very
familiar with these Notions
acquainted with them and therefore I
don't want to go into technicalities but
most of these things can be extended in
various directions
okay
so
on the cube we can also consider the
standard hummings metric so the distance
between two points X and Y two vertices
is just number of coordinates on which
these two purposes differ which is
obviously the same as as the L1 Norm
normalized by a factor of two
okay so this is again the standard thing
and given this
underlying standard measure on the cube
we obviously have for a real valued
function on the cube an expectation
which is just the arithmetic mean of
values of f on in all vertices of the
clip
so this is our basic notation so today's
lecture to the today's discussions will
be mostly related to air to structure so
to things that are related to to the
scalar product structure that we can
introduce on the space of all functions
real valued functions on the cube so the
natural scalar product is obviously
defined as follows we take
just a point wise product of functions
and compute expectation so this is just
normalized
some of the products or values of
functions in all points
and also we introduce some other Norms
not only second Norm but also piece Norm
we just take the expectation of the
peace power of the function f and take
the piece off so we can Define this for
any positive B if p is between 0 and 1
usually this will not be a real Norm it
will not satisfy the triangle inequality
but if p is greater equal than one then
of course you know that this
reasonable Norm on the space of all
functions we also consider F Infinity
which in our case because CN is a finite
structure is just the maximum of the
absolute values of functions on all
vertices and these two notations this
color product and this notation coincide
in the sense that F2 Norm squared is
just denominator that's given by this
color
okay
now given this color product we can
obviously introduce Hilbert space of all
real values functions on the this hit
cube of size and
and it's clear that because the cube has
two in power and vertices the dimension
of a reals of this curable space is
so now what is the Boolean function
among all real values functions on the
cube we can choose some interesting
familial functions that take only two
values and both in the case of the disk
Cube and in the case of the values that
are taken there are many choices so
sometimes people would use zero one in
power n Cube and 0 1 as values for most
of our Apple powers for analytic point
of view it's more convenient than
Transformers that simpler to take a
symmetric Cube negative one one
empowerment and also for the values of
the Boolean function it's more
convenient to take negative one than one
okay but it's just a matter of
Aesthetics obviously by some range of
notation one can switch from one
one description to another I will keep
to this to this way of describing I
think so for me a Boolean function will
be a function that takes values negative
one and positive one
okay and obviously there are many
reasons to study such functions I will
just mention a few of them so one of
them is just theoretical computer
science side you have an algorithm which
takes input of n Bits and produces one
bit as seats out so this is the very
basic thing that that happens and you
want to analyze such functions and
understand their structure
another
thing comes from the branch of
microeconomy that is called social
Choice theory for example management
contributions to this Theory and this
can be viewed as sort of voting so we
have n voters which are distinguishable
and each of them is voting either yes or
no
negative one one and then you want to
have some algorithm deciding about the
outcome of election between two
candidates negative one and positive one
based on how this end voters actually
voted right so any such setting saying
what is the rule how to compute from
Individual votings decisions the general
outcome every such thing will be a
Boolean function and again you may study
different different properties of such
functions trying to optimize some things
that economies or sociologists want to
optimize in such situations
uh
so
obviously voting is just a metaphor
right it's not only about voting but
about all sorts of decision making
economy whenever you have some binary
choice and
again
here there are many simplifications in
this model for example quite often you
have more than two outcomes right so
this is just a first
first approach to such problems usually
the space of values possible values
maybe like five elements for example in
many practical problems but to start
with this is a very natural thing just
modeling such things as binary choice
between two alternatives
okay this helps natural way to view the
Boolean function is combinatorics
and we can just view such functions as
family of subsets of of the set of
integers from one up to n right you have
some n element set and you consider some
family of its subsets so this can be
encoded
in the form of a Boolean function
and there is one to one correspondence
right because we have obviously a
correspondence between a single subset
of this set
to the vertex of the cube right you just
look at the Quality Knights and you say
that coordinates that are negative one
mean that this
uh these numbers fall into the subset
and you exclude all the other indices
right so there is one to one
correspondence between subsets of of an
element set and vertices of the cube and
therefore Boolean function just tells
you what family of subsets you choose
right so this is another natural
motivation for studying Boolean
functions on the on the display
just to understand the computer topics
okay so now the very basic example of
Boolean function uh and the very useful
one is a Welsh function so there are two
in power and walls functions that
appeared also in Adam's talk that the
previous stock today and they were
called parity functions there so I will
use the name Walsh function
because mathematical Community I think
it's more common
so given a subset of
bracket n
we Define a function of the disk tube
just by taking the product of all
coordinates of the pointer X which fall
into the settings
so this is just a multilinear function
if you want to view the cube as a subset
of RN right you have n-dimensional Cube
you can view it in a natural way as a
subset of RN and then this is just a
multi-linear function or a monomial
if you like and of course natural
convention is that if s is the empty set
then the
respective voltage function is constant
equal to one on the whole Cube
okay so now in literature quite often
the Walsh functions that are in this
indexed by the single atoms by the sets
containing only one element I they will
be quite often described as RIS and they
will be called radamaha sequence or
Rademacher variables or
improbabilistic language as independent
symmetric plus minus one Bernoulli
random variables right this is yet
another way to view the Discord Cube
that was in fact mentioned in the very
beginning we can view the discrete Cube
just as a product probability space and
then our eyes are nothing other than
coordinate projections so we are reading
from the marginals
so because this is a product measures
these projections will be independent
random variables okay so this is
just many ways of
seeing the discount coupon related to it
yet there is yet another approach to the
Discord Cube you can just view the
desert Cube as I told you before as a
subset of RN and just consider the
discount Cube as a set of vertices the
set of extreme points of the solid cube
and this approach would come rather from
a functional analysis from convex
geometry and also this way of viewing
the group had some impact on the
development of this year right so the
menu
overlapping ways to to view these things
and this is useful to to somehow keep in
mind all possible ways to to view the
same thing from different angles
okay so now Auto normality that also was
discussed by Adam so we have the
following property that expectation of
the walls functions is equal to zero
whenever s is different from the empty
set and of course if we have the wall
syntax by empty set it's identically
while so the expectation is one this is
Trivial just because as we have set a
moment ago the Welsh function is the
product of independent and the variables
right so expectation of the product of
independent random variables is product
of expectations and of course each of
them is expectation zero right so the
only way to get non-zero expectation is
just when the product itself is empty
so this is a trivial observation another
trivial Observer version that was
already mentioned by Adam but uh I will
just give a more detailed explanation to
that is orthonormality of walls
functions so if you take a point-wise
product as just as a functions on the
cube of two words functions ws and WT
what you get is the Walsh index by the
symmetric difference of the sets s and t
this is Trivial on the example which I
give here you just take for example wall
syntax by the set one two and set two
three so when you
take the product you will see that the
square of
R2 can be killed just because radama has
take only values negative one and
positive one right so the square is
identity one okay so you can see that
exactly in the same way all things all
indices that fall both into s and t will
be killed
and the indices that don't appear
neither here nor here will not will not
appear in this Index
right so because of this identity
we see that this color product of WS and
W2 is expectation
of this world function and because we
know that this expectation is zero if
and only if this set is not empty this
means that this is
which means that this is zero if s is
different from T and one if s is equal
to T right so this means that all
functions form an orthonormal system
and
as every orthonormal system in Hilbert
space this means that they are linearly
independent
and we know that our hearable space has
a dimension to empower and
right so we have independent
independent set of vectors of carbon
narrated to in power and in the real
birth phase of the same Dimension so
this means that this is just a basis
okay but there is also a more
straightforward argument that I want to
show you because I think there is some
value in understanding how it works so
to prove that Walsh function spun in the
space of all functions we can proceed in
a more direct manner so it's enough to
see that an indicator of a single vertex
function that takes value 1 at a single
vertex Y and zero elsewhere that this
function can be expressed as a linear
combinations of Walsh functions but this
is Trivial you just take the product of
1 plus x y y y divided by 2 okay so if x
differs from y
at uh and the coordinate then the one of
the terms that you multiply will be zero
and the whole product will be zero right
so this product will be non-zero if I
don't leave X and Y match on all
coordinates but then all terms will be
one and the product will be equal to one
okay so this is a typical identity and
now you can just multiply everything
with everything getting too Empower and
summons and you can easily see that this
one is just in this form okay so now
every function f obviously can be shown
can be expressed as a linear combination
of indicator functions and because we
can expand the indicator function in the
way that we have seen here and we can
change the order of summation this
helped just to finance I mean summation
so there is no problem with exchanging
the orbitals
of addition we arrive at this formula
which shows that every function can be
expressed in as a linear combination of
all function and actually we get already
the form of the coefficients right which
is nothing unexpected I guess all of you
have seen such things somewhere during
The Graduate Studies but this is just to
remind you how these things work and how
you can see it more directly on the
Discord queue
okay so we have proved in more than one
way than every function
on the disk tube admits one and only one
expansion of this salt this is called
Walsh Fourier expansion and the
coefficients that appear here
are called towards familiar coefficients
sometimes it's abbreviated just to the
Fourier expand
uh so we we have
we have a simple formula allowing us to
read the coefficients from the function
just by taking for walls functions
and in particular for every function we
have a nice way to describe what is the
coefficient the Fourier coefficient
related to the empty set this is by
definition this color product with
Welsh index by the empty set which is
just the constant function one so this
is just expectation this is I think that
you should remember that expectation of
function is encoded in the Fourier
coefficients related to the empty set
the second thing that was mentioned by
Adam in his talk is the plan travel
identity which says that the expectation
of the square of f is the sum of squares
of all four layer coefficients
and let me just recall the standard
proof of this fact this expectation is
not increase than this color product of
f with itself we expand f
into the Wall Street expansion here we
do the same just we denote the summation
index differently now we use linearity
of the scalar product
and we interchange the summation order
okay and now we know that this color
product is equal to one when s is equal
to T and it's equal to zero otherwise so
that's the end so this is very standard
thing that all of you have seen that
harmonic analysis
okay so now let me just say in few words
something that I will totally skip in in
all my lectures but this is a very
special case of marginal theory that is
called LCA theoret so
people realize of course quite long ago
that you can do four-year transform and
all sort of harmonic analysis not only
on real line or unit circle or integers
or negative one one but more generally
on locally compatibilian groups and
there is whole you see always some some
parts of it quite complicated describing
how to do all the stuff including
Fourier transform and
expansions in different settings so
CN
the Discord queue is just a very special
case of this locally compact abelian
group setting more interesting from this
theoretical point of view
perspective the more interesting thing
is control group when n is infinite and
in fact you can consider either a
countable infinite product or even in
some in some branches of topology or
harmonical analysis people who would be
interested in taking
in taking this structure with
with product of uncountable
to point spaces right still this would
be compact thing with the standard
product the topology
and still you can do analysis on it of
course there are some problems with
measurability then and in most settings
you can only consider a functions that
live on the space that is the
uncountable product of the point spaces
that are actually the values of this
function dependently on cantabriel
coordinates right so this is sort of
tricking on the only fossil functions
you can you can really get measurability
and do real analysis but still from
topological or functional analytic point
of view considering such spaces is
sometimes interesting they can Surface
examples in some nice mathematics but I
will completely drop on this thing I
will not talk about that I want to keep
to the finite dimensional simple setting
this is just to tell you that such
things exist
also from this perspective it's
interesting to load that CN the the
discard cube with group
structure when you consider just
pointwise coordinate wise multiplication
that's the code action
on this side
from this point of view and from the LCA
point of view this is a self dual goal
which means that when you apply the
Fourier transform twice
we just defined a moment ago two times
right you have a function you read from
this function the set of the Fourier
coefficients this is again a function
that can be viewed as a function defined
on the discrete Cube right you have to
in power and the subsets and we know
that we can identify subsets of the
bracket and with vertices of the
additional Cube and when we do that we
get a new function that again lives on
the discrete Cube so we can take the
fully transform again right or we can
think about how to take the universe
from the transform to get our function f
and back so when you look at this you
will see that actually uh
this transform applied twice returns you
something very similar to your function
up to some reflection and
rescaling and remember that with
classical Fourier transformation real
line you also have some constant Factor
jumping out and and the reflection
problem right so this is the generality
in the setting
and this is again just the special case
of this lcacr that I want to
start so yes this is the LCA framework
capture Fourier analysis on gaussian
Space stairs uh
uh I guess so it just depends
what you call lca's Setting right just
because they start with the structure
without any measure underlying case and
then they consider higher measure right
so if you do it this way then you would
need some group action such that the
higher measure would be gaussian mesh so
directly I don't see any anything of
this sort but then you can view the
gaussian space as a sort of limit thing
right so in context geometry for example
is quite common
way of seeing the Gauss space as a
projection from high dimensional spheres
right and on high dimensional spheres of
course you have action of groups and
Harmony and so on so in proper sense
gaussian measure can be viewed as a
higher measure it's a projection of
higher measurement at least right so of
course the answer is positive if you if
you face it properly
but something just happens when you
finally captures the
analysis harmonic analysis on the line
yeah but the question was about measure
I understand yeah okay so in general I
mean the thing was done with respect to
the heart measure but you can use it to
do these things about the spaces with
gaussian measure under light
yeah I'm not quite sure the
gaussian protection corresponds to the
case where you you have
unitary action which is
I don't say that this fits into the
setting but I say that from things that
you can do
on even on high dimensional cubes you
can quite often reduce the consequences
for the gaussian measures so quite many
statements are in fact that useful
gaussian space just for proving things
in the in the Discord queue
situation or counter group and then
using some sort of central limit CRM
just to get the limit statement right so
so you can if you agree to view the real
line with gaussian measure as the limits
as sort of a limit
production of of the disk Cube then you
can translate many statements about
Fourier transform from the cube to the
real line with the gaussian measure
right
whenever you have a function on real
line you can leave it lift it up to the
symmetric enough function on the Discord
queue function depending on the sum of
coordinates for example and then you can
compute different properties for example
for the attachment and then you can come
back trying to read this in the context
of real language
that's a quite common perspective
and another thing
not by the use of this Central limit
here and but some sort of equivalent of
central limits here I mean the convex
geometry would be to consider High
dimensional spheres so there is
something that is called sometimes
principle even though actually it comes
from the mid 19th century and it was
known to physicists before uponkara that
when you take just her measure the
normalized layback measure on the
n-dimensional
sphere in just like in canonically in a
euclidean way in RN and then you project
to First K coordinates when K is fixed
and if you take the radius of the sphere
to be square root of n then in the limit
on this projection to First Sky
coordinates will attempt to Decay
dimensional standard gaussian measure
okay so and again because you have a
higher measure on this on this sphere
and you can do things there that are
sometimes nicer than what you can do on
discrete Cube you can deduce things
but of course High dimensional spheres
are not groups right we know that
four-dimensional
three-dimensional sphere will come from
quarter nonsense and Taurus
S1 will come from complex numbers right
but
higher up there is no no groups except
right so it shouldn't be understood this
way
okay so let's come back to the simple
things
so how to compute this works for your
transform so the knife at all would be
if you want to compute it you do it for
each
s for each subset of bracket and
separate right so that knife I broke
who suggest that one would need more or
less quadratic in the data size
operations number of operations right
because for each vertex you need to take
into account values of function in all
vertices it's quite clear to see that if
you change the value of function at a
single vertex it affects the Fourier
coefficients with each of them right so
so we really need to use the values in
all vertices and if you do this for sets
s
one by one you really would need to like
2 N squared operations
more or less
however as I guess most of you know
mattress operations are needed so in
fact
like only logarithmic terms
must be added
so if you are able to compute to somehow
pack if you have enough memory in your
computer and enough time to pack the
data to pack the function f itself then
usually you will have absolutely no
problem with putting in the memory and
doing it in reasonable time with one
through the accounts okay so now how how
to do that this is a typical Davida thin
para method so
we divide our n-dimensional Cube into
two substance
which are just n minus one dimensional
facets okay so we have our high
dimensional Cube and now we split this
into two n minus one dimensional phases
so each of them is the Discord cube in
dimension and minus one so assume that
you can compute the one short rate
Transformer of the function restricted
to this phase and they wouldn't show the
attention of the function was referred
to this phase okay so then this is an
easy exercise and I would advise it to
all of you who don't see it now
told those of you who are not
experienced with that sort of thing I'm
not sure whether there is a single
person in the audience who wouldn't know
that but just in case so this easy
exercise is that you can put together
the world through your function also
here expansion of this function and work
for the expansion of this function and
from these two things you get divorce
for your transform of the whole function
on the on the whole Cube and in fact you
need very simple operation on the
addition subtraction and division by two
so if you want to implement it in
computer this is
so now if we denote by Tau n the number
of operations needed to compute the
launch rate as one CN then we have is a
bound of this thought right we split
into two faces of lower Dimension and
then to put them together we need some
constant times to empower an operations
okay but then dividing this inequality
by two in power and on both sides we see
that the growth of this thing is Sabrina
so
so we have proved that we don't need
many operations right okay so just
coming back to the thing that I said
here that you can identify the subsets
of bracket and with vertices of the cube
and but this is good to
see the discrete cube in many different
ways let me just give you some other
simple homework exercise for those of
you who are not completely familiar with
all of that again my assumption is that
when you make a boot camp there should
also be some class about how to tie your
shoelaces so this is more or less what
I'm doing here
so assume that you have two families of
subsets A and B are two families
subsets
some an element Saturns two families of
each substance and then we can do
something that I will call parity track
sort of
so given s that is also the subset of
this we can compute parity
foreign
way
this is just the cardinality of the set
of all
those
subsets from the family A
that the cardinality of a intersected
with s is even
and in the same way obviously we
find
parrot
function
amidi B
the homework for those of you who don't
see it in this moment
and I'm sure most of you know the answer
is that if forever as
it already tracks agree
then this implies that the family Sr
this is a
family subsets are the same a bit more
delicate question that you can ask is
assume that these are not equalities but
you know that PSA minus PSB
are in some ways small
whatever this means you can quantify it
somehow
the deals from it that the
a symmetric difference will be
more or less
already found it this may be a bit
simpler
this again
this is a bit simpler if you assume
notation is just a bit simpler if you
assume additionally that these two
families of subsets are of the same size
expression B
nice okay and in fact you can express
exactly cardinalito of this symmetric
difference
as a function of these differences right
so most of you probably see in the
second how to do that those who don't
see think about it this is a good
exercise
how how the discard Cube
interpretation in terms of substance
works
okay and of course this is all together
not to reveal if you ask this question
in different ways for example you can
now ask and what if I restrict not to
all S's but only to some family of
substance what can I then say about what
I can read about the family's A and B
why and but then it becomes much much
more complicated this is just
there is a beginning of things that's
that are not bad
after all okay
so now let's proceed
now let me introduce another very
familiar object that I'm sure some of
most of you have seen before so we'll
consider a discrete symmetrical and work
on the cube so this is yet another thing
that we can do to this poor Cube we can
see it as a graph right this is the
graph that has two in power and vertices
and it has
n times to empower an address between
vertices right we say that the address
when the two vertices are neighboring
which means that two vertices are
neighboring if and only if they differ
on exactly one coordinates
okay uh and now we can consider a Markov
chain a random walk on this graph so for
the simplicity
we'll start
with random work
with begins in the 0.111
we start at this vertex at this time
t equal to zero the time is discrete the
time changes every second
it's this takes only positive
non-negative values
and what we do is we jump from the
vertex at which we are at a given moment
to one of its neighbors
and each neighbor is selected with
probability one over n okay and we do
that independently of what happened in
the past of our work right so
or most likely speaking we do a Markov
chain with this transition Matrix
okay
so this is exactly what I wrote here
right YT
describes our position at time T So at
time 0 we are in this vertex
and then the probability the transition
probability from y to X
is 1 over n whenever these are neighbors
they are Hamming distances
okay now
given this position
random variable YT we can also get a
density probability density f t of X is
just the probability that at time T we
are in point x
this will be our way to describe these
things and obviously at point zero at
the moment zero our function is just
this product right if n of x i is
negative one
if the point x isn't at this point then
the product is equal to zero other just
in this vertex we get one right so this
is just indicator of of this point
and that's good because this is how we
want to start and again we know how to
expand this into the arithmetic mean of
all World functions so this is our
starting point
and now obviously because of our Mark of
Markov chain rule the transition rule we
can compute F in time t plus one just
from Ft by a very simple formula we take
the probabilities of being in all
neighboring vertices at time t
and their arithmetic mean will be the
probability that in time t plus 1 will
be in in some vertex X right
because that's the only way we can be at
time t plus 1 at point x but in the time
T were in one of the neighboring
vertices right and this is just the
standard
total probability formula
okay so uh
K is just a linear operator on our
Hilbert space right it's easy to see
that this is linear with respect to the
function f and multiplication by
Scholars the real Scholars so we can say
that ft is K in power tf0 understanding
this is just the power of linear
operator
okay and now
this is a formal definition interesting
from the point of view of our Markov
trying but now see how this works on
particular functions on our launch
functions which are special functions
and we want to investigate them closer
so I claim that the Walsh function is
actually the eigenfunction of this
operator and we can compute its eigen
value which will be given by this
formula why is it so just because when
we are at point x
and we take these neighbors that will be
exactly n minus the cardinality of us
Neighbors at which the value of of the
wall function will be exactly the same
right because this coordinates that
don't fall into us don't notice whether
we change the coordinate or not
and there will be exactly s coordinates
in which the sign of the function will
be changed
Neighbors at which the sign of the
function will be exactly opposite to the
sign of this world function at point x
right because once we change our
coordinate that forms into the set X the
products will change sign
okay so the outcome is of this form
so we have proved that
the walls functions form a
eigenfunction basis
K by the way can be easily tracked to be
asymmetric operator
so this is just orthogonal basis for for
a symmetrical copyright that's that's
standard thing but what is nice is not
only that such
eigenfunctions exist which is the the
general statement about symmetric
materials and symmetric operators but
they are of particularly nice form right
in this this whole functions
so somehow this is another way to view
the world's functions
before that we viewed Walsh functions
either as a products of independent
random variables from a value District
point of view or as characters on the on
the compound group if we took the
harmonic analysis support but here they
are just
eigenfunctions uh a nice description of
of some laplation some LaPlace operator
related to this work on the on the cube
right so there are many perspectives
that can be taken here
uh okay and
this is just a technical terminology in
the language of harmonic analysis K
would be called a multiplier just
because the way K acts on the functions
can be described by understanding how it
multiplies the elements of the standard
basis WS right so this is a standard
multiplier operator
okay so now we know exactly how K in
power T would act on Welsh funds right
this is eigenfunction we know the values
of the thing will just be in power T
sorry there is a typo here there should
be WS at this point
stop us missing and therefore
the function f t
which is what happens after time t with
our point right this is the density
of uh of our points presence on the cube
After Time t
this can be described in the following
way right just because we remember that
F0 was an arithmetic mean of all World
functions right so because of linearity
of the operator KT we have this
expansion so we have very explicit
formula for the presence of our particle
that is moving
randomly on the cube okay and now notice
that these coefficients are strictly
less than one actually bounded away from
one
unless s is the empty set or S is the
whole
the whole bracket n
right the absolute value of this
will be always between negative one and
this will be always between negative one
and one so absolute value will be
circular than one which means that we
should subtract these two terms that
don't don't underlie this principle the
term associated with the empty set and
the hold back again
then the Infinity Norm the maximum Norm
can be bounded by this in power t
right just because the Welsh functions
are Boolean they are bounded by one
in absolute value so we have this bound
and this
goes exponentially to zero when T goes
to Infinity okay so we have obviously
recovered a basic facts from this year
of Markov chain this is some sort of
ergody city right in a very special case
and with a very particular very explicit
formula
okay now recall that the walls
that is related to the empty set is just
equal to one everywhere and the walls in
that two uh by by the full full bracket
and is what is sometimes called parity
function uh which is just the product of
all all other markers so this means that
in even times
when we have time to T when T is
integral this function will return and
very quickly exponentially in t to this
function which is nothing else than the
function that is the equidistributed on
all vertices that have the same
um
when you add the coordinates as n
and uh and here it will tend to to the
other group so
the cube is always a bipartite graph if
we color
if we color this vertex in black and
neighboring vertices in white and
neighboring to them in black and so on
we will just split the cube into two
disjoint set of the same cardinality
black and one and white so that the
black vertices will only have white
neighbors and white vertices will
already have black Neighbors
and that's exactly what happens here
so because we started from the black
vertex in even points of time we can
only be in Black vertices so the
limiting measure will be equidistributed
over all black vertices
and in odd points of time we'll always
end up in white vertex and in the end
our measure will be equidistibuted over
the set of wide vertices right so this
is a very specific case of ergody city
which is not full Ergo decision just
because we have this bipartal structure
right and in periodicity involved
so this is what I said
okay so now we can modify this example a
little bit just to prevent the splitting
to two to two sets of vertices white and
black just to kill in a way the
biparepatite structure on the cube and
this is a very standard thing that I
guess most of you heard before about
this is called lazy random walk so we do
as before from each vertex we move with
the equal probability to each of the
neighboring vertices but we add some
parameter Lambda
we just say between zero and one half
and we go to a neighboring vertex with
probability Lambda divided by n
instead of one over n so with
probability one minus Lambda we stay at
the place in which we were in the
beginning of
of our move okay
so sometimes this random work doesn't
move almost at all especially when
Lambda is very close to zero right this
is why it's called lazy random work
and now we can also describe this lazy
random work as a modification of our
previous
this time random work by some
non-deterministic time change so for
those of you who are more familiar with
with this sort of approaching
probability but I I will not go in this
direction this is just to say that this
is obvious to those who know the
techniques and now let's see what
happens to our density of presence
function in this case
so again ft of X is probability that our
process in this case lazy random work is
in point x at time T so now the starting
point we we do one more minor
modification we start not from this
vertex one one one one one but now we
start from some new vertex
say vertex maybe this from vertex V this
is our starting vertex at point zero we
are here and then we move over the cube
according to this rules
so now uh the difference is that F0 of
course will be slightly different F 0
will be given by this formula right and
again you see that if x differs from V
at any coordinate this term would be
zero and therefore the whole product and
the only X for which this is equal to
one this product is just x equal to B so
F 0 is concentrated this is just an
indicator of the of the vertex V from
which we start at T equals zero okay and
again multiplying everything you get
this expansion that you have seen before
okay so now we see that the the
role of passing from T to t plus 1 is
very similar to the one before but we
have a slightly different operator Kai
Lambda which can be very easily seen to
be just a linear combination of the alt
operator and identity right with
probability one minus Lambda we don't do
anything
and with probability Lambda we do what
we did before
okay so because we know what are the
eigen functions I'll get values for
these and we know that these are walls
functions we can compute easily Diagon
values for K Lambda and World functions
are again eigen functions of this
operator
and as before we get the density of
presence function at time T just
by applying this operator of the
expansion of F0 that we started with
here
so using the multiplier structure of
this operator we arrive at this formula
but now the difference is that because
Lambda is positive this term will be the
absolute value of this of this term
will be strictly less than one in all
cases except s equal to the empty set
okay so somehow we killed this special
case of s being the bracket and the
whole end by introducing this uh small
positive Ram
okay so now
we have the same situation as before but
the convergence is simpler it doesn't
depend on the parity of the time
and we have a uniform and exponentially
fast again
convergence but of course the speed of
this convergence may be quite slow even
though exponentially if Lambda is close
to zero the closer gets to zero the
closer this processor resembles the
process that we had before right so
so this is the price that we pay for for
this approach but anyway this
exponentially fast
converges to the constant function to
empower negative n right because the
only thing that will remain when T goes
to Infinity is think related to The
Walls indexed by the empty set which is
the constant function right
so we'll have in the limit equal
probabilities on average right so this
this is the full strength ergotic CRM on
the district cube right and then we have
a very precise formula allowing you to
control the situation quite well much
better than the than the usual segments
of the robotics here are very explicit
formulas so the mass is actually not on
the lower levels but on the middle level
that can converge even faster life yeah
yeah of course having this formula you
can you can do much smarter and bounce
that what what I just said and knowing
something something more about uh
about how this function evolve with time
yeah that's the advantage of this
formula that you can actually get much
better convergence and not only in terms
of uniform but also other sorts of
convergence if you like right so this is
just to to keep in the very simple
argument setting but but you are
obviously right and that's the main
advantage of the support that you that
you get a full information about
evolution of this density function and
therefore you can
you can control it much better
okay
okay so where does it lead us to
our
our direction is to see that actually
this lazy work when Lambda is small
close to zero uh
Almost Doesn't move right so because of
the law of large numbers it moves only
in a Lambda fraction of the time moments
and therefore it's very natural to us
actually what happens not at the time T
but at the time T is held by the factor
of Lambda that is the natural object the
limiting object that that you would like
to see
and by easy computation we take this
formula and take this linear train
travel and so on you see that when
Lambda goes to zero you don't get the
trivial thing that we started with just
the standard
discounts walk on the cube but you get
something Iris that is described by this
formula okay and now we can do this
thing not only for the process starting
from the vertex V now we can randomize
the starting point we can say that we
start from
the discount Cube and our
distribution of of position in the time
zero is is just some described by some
non-negative function F0 and such that
these things add up to uh to one which
may be read from the empty set Fourier
coefficient in the
in the expansion of the function
and we now see that if we have this
expansion of our initial distribution
then
this rescaled
lazy random work tense when Lambda goes
to zero to such a particular object and
we will see in the future that this is
very canonical thing
but here we first see it limiting as a
appearing as a limiting behavior of the
lazy random work on the cube okay
so let me just mention one thing just as
in real harmonic analysis
it's easier to compute the expectation
of function or the sum of values of
function as here from the Fourier
coefficient you just take the four
recognition related to the empty set in
our case but it's not that easy given a
function f in its Fourier expansion to
track whether it's non-negative
this is just some warning right this in
the same sense when you have a function
on real line
and you take its full so you say it's
even just to keep so that the foreign
transform is also a real valued function
it's not that easy to read whether
function is non-negative or not from its
Fourier transform right
such functions are called
positive definite in proper sensors and
this is an important class of function
but it's not that easy to determine
whether a particular given function
satisfies this right so this is just a
short warning that it's easy to check
that these things are probabilities here
that they add up to one
by looking at this very coefficient but
it's not that easy to see what when you
have given such a full year all fully
especially it's not easy to track
whether this give really gives you some
good distribution in particular whether
it's not negative in all points right
this is just a warning that not
everything is as simple as as usual SIM
from this
the phone okay so now let's let's look
at this thing from yet another
perspective but which will be closely
related so now let's take NT to be the
standard poisson process so for those of
you I guess most of you heard about
standard person process before but this
is the random thing that takes only
integer values and it's non-decreasing
so here we have the real line
and in the points of time that are just
real numbers at point zero we are at
zero
here we take values 0 1 2 3 4 and so on
and the moments of drum
are chosen as exponential with
parameter one
and here
the time that is needed for the next
jump is again exponential with parameter
one and and here again and again and all
this jump
all this time distances between
consecutive jumps are independent
so this is the probabilistic way to
describe the the poisson process
it jumps in random times
which are selected according to the soul
of exponential times but now let me just
try to convey
to those of you who are not very
familiar with this sort of object some
basic idea but underlies this and shows
the connection to the lazy random walk
and the thing that we discussed a moment
ago because things that we will show up
in a moment may seem a bit mysterious to
you
if you don't understand this connection
so imagine
that instead of the clock that is uh
that is somehow measuring this
exponential
exponential timing that you need right
the usual way to describe this is that
you have some Geiger meter and some
radioactive material right that's a
common
thing we applied
world how to simulate such things right
and the moments of ticking of the geiger
counter are exactly the moments in which
you increase and the number of the of
the of the radioactive incidents that
will be just the value of the of the
person process but now let's take a
different perspective let's see this
croissant process as a limiting object
so imagine that you have some little
dwarf hidden uh who is
tossing a coin and this coin is very bad
personally biased so with probability
one minus Lambda
Lambda is close to zero this is the same
Lambda that we discussed before with
probability one minus Lambda nothing
happens
our dwarf doesn't do anything but with
probability Lambda it kicks some
radioactive atom causing it to split
right and send the signal to Geiger
count
so if you scale properly the time
just again dividing by Lambda in the
limit of such small dwarf acting in our
in our cage and simulating the the
splitting of radioactive material in the
limit you will get the again the
exponential distribution right there
will be some geometric distribution that
in the limit after describing will go to
exponential ones right so that's the
connection between these two things
uh
so what we have done
this limit transition is the same
transition that would happen here if we
simulated this by the Discord time and
proper time scaling that's exactly the
same thing okay but this can be also
defined in a more abstract way and in
fact this is a not completely trivial
mathematical theorem saying that
well there is a unique afterward
distribution integer valued Markov
process with independent passion
increments which means that 40 greater
than less
the difference has the same distribution
as ND minus s so it depends on the only
on the difference between TNS and this
is the poisson Distribution Center
poisson distribution with parameter D
minus s okay
but that's the same object as here
uh uh and that's more or less what I
said
and now having this Standard poisson
Process we consider another standard
object but maybe a bit less popular
which is called poisson parity process
so we take this process n of T and
forget about everything except its
parent so we take negative 1 in power n
of t so if n is even this will give you
the value 1 and otherwise it will give
the value of negative one so n will be
negative 1 1 valued it will jump between
negative one and one which is exactly
what we like because we want things to
happen on the digital Cube negative one
we're having power n minimum okay so
this is what happens
and now there is just a short warning to
those of you who are not very familiar
with Markov processes so it's not true
that when you have a Mac of process and
you put a function on each composite of
some function then you get again a
Markov process such gluing May destroy
the mark of proper but in this
particular case this will be a markup
process just because of the symmetry of
the objects
the definition of markup processes that
if T1 and T2 are two times and m t 2
minus T1 is to be independent of T1
the definition would be that the mark of
property is satisfied so when you
condition over the presence is the same
as conditioning of the peasants with the
past are that more or less
that that would be my definition right
so it's not that the increment has to be
independent or something
um
you can model you can model every Mark
of process in this way right but
formally informally when you have a
sequence of random variables let's say
with numbers by you
positive non-negative indices when you
have a sequence let's say that the size
space is finite
for simplistic
so all of them have values in E then I
would say that this is
markovian that this satisfies micro
property if probability that X in moment
t plus 1 is equal to some
fixed value it in mind
under condition that x t is equal to e t
it's the same as probability
plus one
no of course one should say what happens
when the probability of the event under
which the condition is equal to zero and
so on I don't want to get but basically
that is what I mean by by the markup
Foundation but of course you can
rephrase it in in other ways if the
mapping is
if it's a byjection then then obviously
it doesn't destroy the mark of property
but this one isn't a by Direction it
grows all odd numbers into negative one
and all the even numbers into positive
one right so subtle gluing May destroy
the mark of property in in fact in most
situations it does but this in this
particular it's easy to track that it
doesn't that the mark of properties
preserves due to the symmetry of the
objects underlying more or less
if the transition mechanism that is
the transition Matrix that is hidden in
this Markov chain is in a way consistent
with the way you glue things than the
mark of property will that's the case
here
so now we can actually compute the
transition probabilities for this person
process
so this is a very simple transition role
given
so this is transition from one to one
this is from negative one to negative
one and both of them depend only on
difference between time T and S and are
given by this formula and transition
from negative one to one or one to
negative one changing the flipping
design is given by this one okay so
let's compute this probability just to
show you that this is easy this is
probability that the difference of the
poisson process the usual process
between Time s and the t is even under
condition that at Point S at the time s
this was even
okay but now we know that this increment
is independent of of what happened at
the time as this is just this
conditioning is therefore
just equal to probability that this
random variable is even and this you can
compute this is just the croissant
distribution of the set of even numbers
right so you express it as a sum you see
that this sum is just power series for
this policies for this the odd terms
will cancel out and and you you end up
with the mix formula for that okay and
now you obviously get this probability
as 1 minus this probability they must
add up to one and just because M takes
only values of negative and positive one
so from that you get this probability
and of course for these computations are
exactly the same so I skipping this one
okay
so now I should have said that just
because we know what happens about the
flips uh the the time of jumps for the
person process we see that for our
process again the sine flips of the
process M will be
separated by independent exponential
random variables of course theorem it
might happen that the person process
jumps from zero immediately to three for
example right
some constructions allow this sort of of
behavior but that would happen only with
probability zero right so it's
negligible from the probability Sigma
interview right it happens only with
probability zero such such science
Behavior so
therefore for our parent process also
the drums which are now flips between
negative one and one are separated by
independent times in each of them with
exponential distribution okay now just
to simplify the formula we slow the time
two times
we rescale it by a factor of two
just to get rid of these tools here
and now notice that this process is both
time and space homogeneous
it's time homogeneous just because it
only takes into account what happens as
a difference between TNS and the
transition Matrix doesn't depend on
anything else but it's also space
homogeneous because it doesn't really
see the difference between negative 1
and positive one there was the symmetry
of the probability transactions right so
so this is a very natural object this is
what I mainly want to say that
it's not only defined in a very precise
way but also it's a very natural object
and in fact
such an object a process flipping
between 1 and negative one
which underlies these transition rules
this sort of Markov chain can be
concerted completely out of scratch you
don't need to start with a person
process you don't need to have this
limiting object you can do that
immediately just by checking that the
Chapman called comograph equations for
this transition probability is called so
those of you who learned something about
stochastic processes know that if you
check the Chapman chromograph equation
that will show up in a moment
and they are consistent
they are exactly the way in which the
consistency is checked then by the
column of consistency or so-called
extension theorem there is a stochastic
process that is realizing uh that is a
mark of process will this transition
start okay so this is just to show you
how use a different method to construct
this object so now let's take three
times U T and S U is the largest time
and S is the earliest
until somewhere in between so the
Chapman Commodore thing that we need to
track
is the following that the probability of
going from X to Z in time between s and
U and because of the time homogeneity we
need only to track the difference of the
times
probability that we go from X to Z
in time U minus s so starting in time as
and times U that's sad should be
given by this total probability formula
so we take all intermediate points
between x and z that we had to pass
through at time t
in our case these are just two points
negative one positive one and we want
this equation to hold otherwise this is
not a good sort of conditional
probability side this thing should up
adapt to this thing to make any sense
right
we just this is the total probability of
going from X to Z between times s and t
and we split it according to where we
happen to be at the time intermediate
time T we call this point Y the time T
and this formula should help but it's
very easy to verify this formula so if x
is equal to Z then we know that this
expression is given by this formula and
now it's very easy to track
we have two points negative one and one
so we don't need to to really take care
about whether X is equal to y or
different from Y in one of the sum in
one of this two expressions it will be
equal and in the other it will be
different X is equal to that so y equals
negative one and y equal 1 will have two
possibilities of being equal or
different from these two points so we
put in
the probabilities that we know from the
previous Slide the ones that we computed
and we immediately see that this is just
algebraic identity and the same is for x
equals negative Z
you can do the same single procedure and
you check just that the Trap and
commodore of equations hard right so
there's a very very direct and simple
way of checking that this object exists
that it may be realized as a stochastic
process without referring to the
and all other stuff it just depends
which approach you prefer
okay and now let's talk about the
continuous random work on the CN so
again we have our diesel structure our
Discord Cube we don't have a Brownian
motion on this script Cube just because
there is no continuity right but as
close as we can get to Brownian motion
we will consider some replacement for
the boundary motion which will be cons
continuous time random work so now our
time is indexed by uh non-negative real
numbers instead of positive integers
and now we take the process x t that we
just talked about on the previous slide
this flipping between negative one and
one Markov process and we take it its
independent copies on each of the
coordinates separately
so on the first coordinate with flip
sign on the second we flip sign
independently of what happens on the
first and so on right we have an
independent sign flipping processes and
now we start our Markov process at some
figures vertex V on the cube
and we Define
our Markov process x view which is the
process starting at Point V
at time 0 in this way we just take the
pointwise the pointwise product of this
sequence with the vertex V with
coordinates of the vertex B
Okay so
since all of these processes started at
point one
will indeed start at Point V
and now it's easy to see what happens
we have n coordinates
and on each coordinate we wait
exponential one time before there will
be a flip of PSI so when will the first
strain occur
when the minimum of n independent
exponential random variables with
parameter one
right that will be the first jump but
what is the minimum of an independent
exponential random variables of
parameter one
this is exponential random variable with
expectation 1 over n which most people
would denote as having parameter n some
statisticians denote this parameter as
being equal to expectation so they will
say that with parameter one over
exponential parameter one is safe
because it doesn't matter which
Community you belong to
uh so that's why I chose this
normalization right so that's exactly
what happens and what happens after that
is completely independent
from what happened before this first
moment of jump okay so what happens is
actually the standard random work you
move from your neighbor to each of
neighboring from your vertex to each of
the neighboring vertices with equal
probability one over n at the time given
by exponential random variable with
parameter uh
well n over two in fact I treat it a
little bit there is this Factor two that
comes from the rescaling you remember
that we throw Time by a factor so this
intervenes here okay so you see that's
exactly our Discord work on the with
this third time
with some random change of time okay
that's with probability zero that's
exactly the same thing that I told about
uh going from person to imperative
person right this may happen
theoretically but with probabilities
also we don't need to care about it okay
so we have this process this is
discontinuous time random work on the
discrete Cube and now we can define
something that is called semigold so
whenever you have a random walk
and a function on the cube you can make
a new function PT of f you have some
real valued function on this you define
the new function PT of f in a following
way at the vertex V
you define this function in the
following way you start a random work
which I just described on the previous
slide at point B you let it run for time
t
you take value of function f at the
heating point and then you take
expectation over all possible
trajectories right over all possible
things that could happen
but this is very easy to write it down
right this is just some of the
distancation probabilities from X from V
to X at time T overall in vertices X of
the cube right this is very direct
um
uh so what are the properties of such
semigo this is obviously linear right it
depends linearly on the function f so
this is a linear operator moreover if
you start with function f that is
constant one
this produces again function that is
constant one this is obvious right so
you just take expectation of one of
something which is
which is just expectation of one which
is one so this is Trivial probability
and this may be read as the invariance
of the underlying measure but that's a
bit treating Just Because We
additionally need this property that
this semi group is symmetric with
respect to this uniform measure on the
Queue so I I would prefer not to read
this condition in these terms later on I
will tell a bit more about about this
nuance
okay and now another condition if we
start with non-negative function then of
course here we'll average something that
is not negative so F being non-negative
implies that PTF is non-negative almost
true
and because this is a linear operator
this is actually equivalent to saying
that PT preserves the order
if you have pointwise inequality between
function f and every this translates to
a pointless inequality between their
images right you just take the
difference and and use linearity of PT
okay so we have a semi group that is
order preserving in particular positive
preserving and it preserves the function
one
okay and now let's check that it
satisfies the semi group property is it
really correct to call it a semi-group
so semi-group property is this fact that
when you take the composition of
operators PT and PS you should get the
operator p with index t plus s that's
the basic property of the semi group and
also we would like P0 to be identity so
P0 being identity is Trivial because at
Time Zero you just don't move in this
process so you stay at the place you
were in the beginning
but this property should be verified
okay so let's see by definition of PT
this is just expectation when you run
for time T starting from
uh when you use this semicop over the
point x v of T right and you take
expectation
so we can write it down as we did before
just as a finite sum
now we can write this thing in terms of
conditional probabilities
just the real way we describe such
random work
and what we have here
is Again by definition of our semigoth
expectation but now we run for the time
as starting from point x
okay
so now we can also write down this
expectation as a sum as a finite sum
and now we can
also change the order of summation
because these are two finite sums
or you you may also use other Arguments
for that but that's the simplest
argument because these are finite sums
and after changing the order of
summation you may put together this
thing
this is just the transition probability
going from X to Y in Time s by our
passes okay but this is already the
Chapman Commodore of thing that we
verified so we've replaced this by PT
Plus s
complete why and we end up
right so this is a very common thing
that's not very particular to this
particular random work on the cube right
this is the way from which having a
Markov process we produce a semi group
and verify that it really satisfies the
the seminal property right nothing
special about our particular random work
on the on the particular sector was used
here except perhaps finiteness of the
structure to to Interchange the
summation
okay
so now having a semi Group which is
indexed by this time parameter
and such that when you take a function
that is square integrable this produces
another Square interview function
and such that the same group preserves
positivity
and preserves concerns constant function
one such semi group will be called
microbial
okay and treating her a little bit just
because when you really enjoy Markov
processes and so on on continuous
structures and there are many other
things to take care about for example
measurability with respect to the space
Not only what happens with respect to
time parameter and then of course you
get into some more technical details but
I will not go there we are interested in
things that happen for the cube okay so
we have proved actually that our PT
defined using continuous time Markov
walk on the Queue
random work on the cube is a Markov
selling
and now
actually
this two things are strongly related
when we have a
Mark of semi group this is actually
related always to some Markov process so
we have seen implication one way we have
seen that when you have a Markov process
you can have a semigo
but also once you have a mark of semi
group you can read a Markov process for
meat and I will only discuss this in the
case of finite State space because it's
trivial and the idea is very easy you
define the transition probability
in the following way you take indicator
function of the single state y
which is the state to which we want to
come in time t for Max we want to Define
this probability
and this is where it's really useful to
have a distance
State space right otherwise having
indicators functions would would not be
enough and we'll have to to deal with
more complicated expression but
on the discrete space that's all that we
need
you take the value of the semi group on
this indicator and value of it at point
x
and that's it this is how you define QT
now there are many questions the
question is are those supposed
transition probabilities non-negative do
they add up to one
actually they do
why are they non-negative they are
non-negative simply because this is
positivity preserving semigo and
indicator is a non-negative function so
they are non-negative they add up to one
here we use linear rate
when you define Q2 qt in this way
you just replace the order here
you'll just create a narrative of Duty
and here we have duty of the indicator
of the whole Space the Consular Function
One
so they add up to one
at time equals zero they are trivial in
the corner Deltas as they should be so
all conditions are easy to verify
and finally
using the same definition that replacing
the rule of X and Y by y and z
we can write the image of the indicator
Z under the semi group in this way such
sum and using this expression
we can very easily verify that QT
defined in this way satisfy the Chapman
chromography equation but I will not
stop on you will get the slides if you
cannot do this computation yourself you
will find it in the in the slides file
so but this is very easy as you can see
just few lines so actually the only
thing that remains is to see that this
Mark of starter that we got the
transition structure is actually the
Markov process that we started with
right we know how to pass from Markov
process to semi-group and we know how to
perform semi group to the Marco forces
but we don't know whether this is one to
one correspondence right we need to know
that we come back to the same thing but
this is actually this is what we need to
verify that when you use this semi-group
QT defined this way you will get
the same expression that that you are
supposed to get but now because of
linearity of both sides it's enough to
verify this equality on indicators and
on indicators this reduces just to the
definition of QT which hands the profile
so somehow
this was just a quick reminder
quick
repetition of the basic Theory how
Markov processes relate to semi-groups
there was nothing specific in what I
described for the cube and the random
mark on the Cuban Zone this is more
General scheme marginal pattern about
relation between semiglobs and markup
processes and in general setting when
you want to have probability of
transitions from V to a you just take
indicator function of the set a
right in finite space this is just easy
consequence of linearity and in more
refined situations when the continuous
State space is student is to be dealt
with you you must play with such
Expressions right this is more
complicated okay so I think I will stop
here
timer over time a little bit and next
lecture we will start with understanding
how the semi-group relates to the
semi-group to the thing that we have
seen before as a limit of a district
random walk after a time of scale we'll
see why this semigo petal is under is of
any interest to people and there are
many reasons for that so thank you